le syndicat des médecins d'aix et région
dépose une plainte disciplinaire contre
le professeur franck chauvin président
du haut conseil de la santé publique il
est accusé de charlotte de charlatanisme
de violation de l'indépendance
professionnelle de déconsidération de la
médecine et de violation du devoir de
prudence lorsqu'une information du
public et réalisé pour en parler nous
sommes avec nicolas ch léché avocat au
barreau de paris maître chollet bonjour
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors après avoir lu cette
première requête rejetée par le conseil
d'état au sujet des masques du dépistage
et de la chloroquine le syndikat les
médecins d'aix et région ne désarment
pas et lance une nouvelle offensive
procédurale pourquoi alors c'est très
simple on est dans une logique assez
globale pour s'attaquer si vous me
permettez d'attaqué de parler un peu du
fonds à ce que on identifie comme dans
un premier temps une démission d'état
qui s'est privé de son indépendance et
on le voit bien on n'arrive pas au bout
de deux mois avoir démasqué et sp2 avoir
des moyens de dépistage et à cette
défaillance dans la gestion de la crise
actuelle qui est là une erreur à court
terme que nous essayons de devenir
contré par différentes requêtes et
différentes actions cette action est
très simple il s'agit d'attaquer le
professeur chauvin qui comme vous le
savez président le haut conseil de la
santé publique
c'est une sorte d'expert d'état et qui a
pu déclarer de manière assez scandaleuse
dans la viande se confesser au canard
enchaîné qui l'avait signé
l'avis du 23 mars du haut conseil de la
santé publique qui réservent usage de
l'hydroxyde rockin vous en avez décerné
entendu parler puisqu'il s'agit d'une
des molécules que l'on relit au
professeur raoult qui ont fait la
promotion alliée à celle de 2 à aix
marseille et dans cet avis du haut
conseil de la santé publique il est
indiqué qu' il faut réserver cet usage à
l'hôpital premièrement évoqua notamment
aux cas les plus sévères or dans le
canard enchaîné
le professeur franck chauvin avoue qu'
il n'y a aucune donnée scientifique ni
actuelle ni avérées de la science qui va
dans ce sens vous avez pu voir qu'il y à
une multitude de professeurs le
professeur douste-blazy le professeur
willy rozenbaum qui explique que c'est
la décision la plus bête qu'il pouvait
être crise et il ya une multitude de
dans la communauté scientifique qui
indique que s'il hydroxy chloroquine est
utile elle ne peut pas être utile à un
stade trop avancé et le professeur
chauvin contre attaque on indique qu'il
a agi sous pression pour laisser c'est
son expression une porte ouverte aux
soignants dans les cas pour les cas les
plus sévères
on s'interroge donc sur l'indépendance
du professeur chauvin qui a cédé à une
pression ce n'est pas du tout ce qu'on
lui nous on ne lui demande de donner un
avis scientifique lui et le haut conseil
de la santé publique et on peut
s'interroger s'il est capable de cdl
telle pression comment peut-il résister
à éventuellement une pression des lobbys
ou des firmes pharmaceutiques
nous avons donc décidé de porter plainte
et de demander au conseil de l'ordre de
déposer une plainte à la chambre
disciplinaire de première instance en sa
qualité de médecin afin qu'ils puissent
se voir appliquer une sanction
disciplinaire qui correspondent aux
violations du code de déontologie et à
son serment d'hippocrate qu'il a pu
violer alors maître chollet vous vous
attendez donc une sanction à travers
cette plainte
on demande dans un premier temps à ce
que le conseil de l'ordre dépose une
plainte et puisse montrer qu'il ne
laisse pas des violations du code est
d'anthologie impunis alors même que je
rappelle qu'on a acquis dans la presse
il ya quelques jours que le conseil de
l'ordre le conseil national de l'ordre
avaient décidé de poursuivre des
médecins qui ont décidé d'appliquer un
traitement mêlant notamment hydroxyque
l'orexine était assis trop bas si on
estime donc que le conseil national de
l'ordre des conseil départemental de
l'ordre correspondantes doivent
poursuivre le professeur chauvin puisque
il a présenté publiquement
dans un avis qui est on ne peut plus
officielle puisqu'il est du haut conseil
de la santé publique un traitement qui
est illusoire puisque il s'est lui-même
que en aucun cas cela peut avoir un
effet sur les cas les plus graves
et j'ajoute d'ailleurs que dans l'espèce
de cabale qui a contre le professeur
raoul on expliqué on met en avant des
effets secondaires et bien alors s'ils
croient eux-mêmes à cet argument si les
effets secondaires sont aussi terrible
que cela
et bien il ne faut pas faire quand un
risque supplémentaire à des personnes
qui sont déjà dans un état fortement aux
dégradés très bien merci beaucoup en
tout cas nicolas chez les avocats au
barreau de paris nous avoir éclairé sur
ce sujet et d'avoir bien voulu répondre
à nos questions